どうも子供にYouTubeの動画を
見せるとき安心できそうで安心できなそう
なYouTuberランキング第4位
はじめしゃちょーです俺今までどれぐらい
動画出したと思うなんと今まで私が出した
動画
2754本もう3000本ぐらいの動画
出してるんですよこれだけ動画があると
色んな動画僕作ってきましたまあ中には
本当にしゃべるだけの動画だったりほぼ
しゃべってない動画とか意味わかんない
動画とかなんかこうちょっとねあのボッと
ちょっと
延長しちゃったりなんか色んな人に褒めて
もらって面白いと言ってもらった動画
いろんな動画があってはじめしゃちょーの
チャンネルが成り立ってるんですけれども
ふとふと私は思いましたこれだけ動画が
あると非常に良くない動画もあるんじゃ
ないかというわけで今回ですねはじめ社長
のお母さんに絶対に子供に見せたくない
動画ランキングトップ5作ってもらいまし
た
お母さんありがとうございますいや気に
なるな結構気になります3人とかアンチと
かじゃなくても実の親
肉親の親から子供に見せたくない動画
ランキング」ってそれ多分ガチだと思うん
すよ結構信憑性の高いかなり的を得た
はじめしゃちょーの子供に絶対見せたく
ない動画ランキングとなっておりますので
ぜひ皆さん楽しんでいってくださいもし
この動画見たら子供たち絶対に真似をし
ないでくれそしてこれを見てる保護者の方
いらっしゃいましたらこの動画だけは絶対
見せないようによろしくお願いします
じゃあ見ていきましょう
早速見ていきましょうはじめしゃちょーの
母が選ぶ絶対に子供に見せたくない動画で
ランキング第5位です第5位にランクイン
したのは
土に埋まる俺を助けてくれる人はいるのか
見事第5位にランクインしましたお
めでとうございます
なんでなんでなんこれ何がダメなちょっと
実際見てみないと分からないけど別になん
かそんな悪いことなさそうですけどね
じゃあちょっと見ていこうと思います
和田
近所の子供たちがいる中で撮ってましたね
[音楽]
何年前なんだろう
埋まってる俺を助けてくれる人はいるの
かっていう企画ですね知らない人が来て俺
を見て助けてくれるかどうか
近所の子供たち今この子たち高校生とか
大学とかなんじゃないかな
たくさんいるね公園の砂場に穴を掘って
助けてくれる人はいるかどうかっていう
動画ですね
だからやろうよ
公園にいる子たち全員許可取って
砂場使っていいって聞いてやってた記憶が
ありますね
くれぐれも知らないように
すごいなちゃんと
埋まってるなぁこれで
首だけの俺を見て誰か助けてくれるか
待つという企画ですね
だいぶシュールだな誰か来た誰か来たぞ
あーどっか行っちゃった助けてくれる人が
なさそうなんでヘルプミアを置いて助けを
すると思うよ
ね
車来ましたね
この子のおかげで動画的にはちょっと
面白くなったっていうやつでしたねはい
こちら第5位でしたはいちょっと実際
お母様に理由を聞いてみたんですけれども
理由としては子供が真似しそうなのでって
いう理由で恋でしたねま確かに俺大きい
からさ大きい大人がこれする分にはまあ
自力で出れますけどもこれ子供が真似して
入っちゃうと自分で出れないし
砂場って結構ね実は危険だったりするので
うちのお母様はそういうとこ加盟して第5
位とランピンさせていただいたんだと思い
ますあのちっちゃい子供はぜひ真似しない
ようにあと砂場もね砂場もね色んな人が
遊ぶ場所だからこういう風に独占しない
ようにねちゃんと周りの人に迷惑になら
ないようにして遊びましょう続いて第4位
です第4位なんとランクイン同率2個2本
の動画があります1個目がですね
1個目が寝てる人を起こさずに電球で
テニス第4位ですおめでとうございます
これはまあシンプルにちょっと理由が
分かるというか他人の家で電球で手に
するっていう企画なんですけどちょっと
もう昔すぎて覚えてないので1回見ようと
思います
アトミックさんですねこの人のお家で寝
てるんすよこの人寝てる人は確かなんか
起こさずにやるんだったかなそういう感じ
だった気がするなあやっぱ静かにやって
ますね
ゴブリン寝てますね
はいはいはいはいはいテニスラケットで
売っちゃうわけですよと何々するんですね
電球でやろうとなるほど
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいはい
[音楽]
そうね電球割れるとすごい音なるので
そうですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
結構音なるな
結構音になりますね
起きなかったので
起きちゃった
あー続けるんだね
[音楽]
[拍手]
最低マジで最低です4位ランクインお
めでとうございますパーからの一言
コメントありますこれも一言危ないっしょ
というコメントを頂いております
ありがとうございます間違いないです
危ないですねこれやっぱトミックさんって
この人との信頼関係があってやっとできて
ますねこれは俺は人ん家だやろうとは思い
ません続いて同率の第4位です次があー
なるほど
検証
画びょう1000個ある床に突然人を
落としたらどうなるのっていうやつですね
これでもねちゃんと画鋲全部抜きました
からそんな危なくはないと思いますけどね
見てみたいと思いますこんにちは
初めてです皆さん画鋲を知ってますかあの
僕結構
嫌いなんですよね見た目が
刺さってないよねやばいなんか敏感になっ
ちゃうやだこれねすごい大変だったんです
けどもわざわざ画鋲の針を1000個分
全部ペンチを抜くという作業をやりました
もう超安全に考慮してやりましたこれもう
本当に
これはなー大変だったなぁはい多分一人で
300本ぐらいなんですけども2時間
くらい安全に考慮してやらせていただいて
いますから
ちゃんとね安全に考慮するとこれだけ大変
だよっていうのをねちょっと俺的には
ポイントというか安全で安全じゃないです
か針抜いてやるとはいで全部抜き終わって
受けましたねさあご覧くださいこれ全部
画鋲なんですはい上から見るともう本当に
ね
普通にこれが一番心配なんだけど
これで痛いとちょっともともともないです
から
[音楽]
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいこういう
感じでスライドさせて
あーこれでドンって落とすのね
[笑い]
そうなるわな
[音楽]
我ながらに面白い
最低ひどいことばっかり言ってるなぁ
まぁまぁでもこれ危ないかって言われると
僕は危ないと思いませんけどね
画鋲の針全部抜いてるし安全に考慮して
危ないこと言ってます
危ないことやってるわあーなるほどね
母親の理由としては
剥けばいいけど
抜かずに真似したらバツと
子供たちを見るっていう考えだとひょっと
したらねそのままやっちゃうっていうこと
もありますから確かに確かにこれはでも
ちゃんと俺が注意深く書かなきゃいけな
いってとこですね動画の前半とかほぼ針
抜くシーンだから結構これ間違えて針あり
でやっちゃう子供はバカそんなバカとは
言いませんけども私は真似されると危ない
かもしれませんね是非ともこれやるときは
気をつけてやってください
断じて針ありでやってはいけませんマジで
怪我します続いて第3位です第3位に
ランクインしました子供に見せたくない
動画は
ついで4足歩行してみたです第3位お
めでとうございます
これはねちょっと僕自身もランクインさせ
たい動画ではあります内容は至って
シンプルなんですよその全て4本買って
あの手足に4本ずつつけて4足歩行し
ようっていう動画をあったんですけども
困るからねだからみんなあんまり真似し
ないでね変なことたまに気をつけなきゃっ
て言った後にこいつ怪我してんだ危ない
ことを真似しないでね気をつけようって
言った動画でこいつ怪我してます4
速でね熱い地面に海とか砂浜も熱くないっ
てことですか結構
あーマジでこの時はマジでいけるって思っ
てたんですよ
ということを知っているだろうか
床に固定して杖を
杖を逆に机に貼ってここに乗ろうっていう
やばいマジでやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばい
肛門肛門
すでに掘られました
この後僕救急で病院に運ばれました
杖が本当に
肛門の中にぶっ刺さっちゃって肛門裂け
ちゃって本当にやばくてもう99で病院に
運ばれた思い出がありますね本当にね
訪問なかなか忘れがちだと思いますけども
ここもかなり危ないですこれなんか最悪の
事態にはならなかったんですけれども結構
危なかった動画ですねこれは単調とかする
人いると思いますけども結構危ないので
ちょっとマジで気をつけてくださいこれは
非常になんか僕自身からも危ないよって
教えたい動画です絶対真似しないで
ください続いて第2位第2位は車の上で
ローション相撲をしてみた台におめでとう
ございますこれどういう動画かというと
東海オンエアのてつやのお母さんの車
てつやの車じゃなくててのお母さんの車の
上に
ローションを乗りたくって相撲をしてみる
という動画ですね今のところ何が危ないか
分からないですけどもちょっと見てみたい
と思いますどうぞというわけで皆さん
若いな2人とも
がっちり
懐かしいなこれ何年前だ
初めて社長の席って書いてあったおー
すごいマジでこいつらやるのかてつやは
キャップ譲ってわかるけど俺はダメだな
確かに人のお母さんの車の上よ
本当にそうよ
[音楽]
確かに子供がこれ乗ってやると落ちると
かなり気がしますねえーとお母様からの
一言コメントによると親の車の上に乗って
はいけない大正論これですねもう
ローションとかそういう話じゃなく人の母
の車の上に乗ることが良くないとコメント
を頂いておりますありがとうございます
続いて第1位
はじめしゃちょーの母が選ぶ子供に絶対
見せたくない動画ランキング第1位は
シナモンチャレンジです
[音楽]
なるほどこれが第一に来ましたかうわー
懐かしい僕がイギリスに留学してた時の
動画ですね
シナモン食べてなんか耐えるみたいな
シナモンチャレンジというのが流行ったん
ですけども
[音楽]
これねほんとちょっと
危ないんですよね
最高で締めくくってますけどまぁこれ
シナモンチャレンジもちょっと危ないね
これまずシンプルに危ないっていう理由で
普通のお母様から1位頂いております本当
におめでとうございます本当にギリギリ
ですねなんか今は絶対やらないですし当時
なんか流行ってたからやってたみたいな
やつもありますけどもほんと探せば探す
ほどねちょっと今だとできないなみたいな
動画も当時はできましたけど子供も真似
するかもしれないなと思ってちょっと気を
つけて動画を撮っていきたいと思いました
子供が真似できないようなことまで
振り切ればできる気もしたのでちょっと
より一層動画作り気をつけていきたいと
思いますはい真似しないよっていう方だけ
動画のリンク下に貼っておきますのでぜひ
見てみてください
[音楽]